historically houses of worship for the
black community I believe is what has
allowed us to keep our sanity as a
people religion in the United States has
been used throughout history not only as
the bedrock of the persecution of black
Americans but also as the bedrock of
their emancipation they made meaning of
Christian teaching about salvation of
biblical traditions regarding liberation
hey guys I'm Sonia and today I'm going
to explore the role of religion
especially Christianity and Islam in the
black American history of liberation and
I want to ask if religion still has a
role to play today in the fight against
systemic racism
[Music]
European colonizers justified slavery
through the Bible there was this idea
that biblically through the story of
Noah's curse Africans were meant to be
slaves but black slaves also went on to
adopt Christianity and make it into a
faith for survival and mobilization what
we know as a black church today form
through what happened during slavery and
the period after it now slaveholders
didn't really want their slaves to be
exposed to Christianity there was a fear
that by exposing them to it they'd see
themselves as well equal to the
slaveholder since they would share the
same faith so they adjusted their faiths
teachings the version of Christianity
has slaveholders spread usually mandated
a divinely ordained racial hierarchy
that slavery was God's will for people
of African descent and it's not like the
stolen Africans didn't have their own
spiritual traditions before they were
enslaved in the colonies I'll let dr.
Judith Weisenfeld at Princeton
University explained enslaved Africans
were not interested in converting to
Christianity for example enslaved
peoples produced religious community on
their own maintaining connections to
African traditional resources and
creating new versions of those their own
beliefs include a variety of traditional
religions in West Africa and Central
Africa but also Islam and Christianity
and they ended up practicing their faith
in secret gatherings but in the 1740s
decades before the United States even
existed a wave of religious enthusiasm
among European Protestants spread across
the colonies it's known as a Great
Awakening the Christian revivals as they
were called too focused on renew to
individual piety and religious devotion
and they had a more egalitarian message
than the one that slaveholders espoused
people felt free to interpret the
scripture and the teachings of
Christianity for themselves in ways that
highlighted their humanity their equal
standing before God and the notion that
God would someday liberate them and so
we begin to see new forms of African
American Christianity emerge that are
focused on this experience of being
born-again and on a more direct access
that doesn't require the oversight of
white clergy it's out of this movement
that you start to see the emergence of
black leaders a lot of them came out of
Baptists and Methodists denominations
because those denominations are actually
licensed black men to preach and
Weisenfeld says sometimes religion even
provided tools for slave revolts one of
the most famous examples that comes much
later is that of nat turner a religious
missionary and preacher who led a
rebellion in virginia in august of 1831
now back in the late seventeen hundreds
of free black people in the north had
already begun to develop their own
denominations in many cases these
denominations were in direct response to
the races and black americans
experienced in their predominantly white
congregations but it wasn't until after
the civil war and the end of slavery
that newly freed black people who were
part of the baptist churches and
communities in the south were able to
organize more formally when the National
Baptist Convention was founded in 1895
it became the nation's largest
african-american denomination with
almost two million members so why is all
of this important well these new
institutions became central spaces for
black organizing and public discussion
of issues like the abolition of slavery
and then later the status of free black
people it gave them a means to mobilize
against their oppression control of of
religious life was always fraught under
slavery but it was sometimes the only
arena in which people could exercise
Authority and control black preachers
black ministers other kinds of black
religious leaders have always been
central figures and black communities
during the Great Migration millions of
southern black people moved to northern
cities in search of better opportunities
and to escape the Jim Crow South it's
estimated that between 1916 and 1917
more than 6 million black americans left
their homes in the south and relocated
to northern cities this influx of
southerners not only transformed
northern black Protestant churches but
also created interactions that would
offer black Americans a range of
religious beliefs outside of
Christianity in our interview Weisenfeld
notes that out of the great migration
came two major revivalist movements that
identified Islam as the proper religion
of black people the more science temple
and the Nation of Islam while Islam was
one of the religions of African slaves
it kind of disappeared as a conscious
faith in practice because slaves were
forced to practice in secret and it was
through the work of Muslim missionaries
scholars and active
that versions of Islam began to
re-emerge in black communities in the
early 20th century versions that
reflected the fight against white
supremacy and a search for independence
a lot of those immigrant preachers
propagated the idea of universal
brotherhood an idea that appealed to
many black Americans noble drew Ali who
is considered the father of the first
modern Black Muslim movement established
the marsh science temple in the early
1900s the Moorish science temple
rejected the idea of tolerating white
supremacy through the black church and
rejected the idea of black inferiority
the temple didn't reject Christianity
but it did see it as a European religion
among the temples central beliefs was
the idea that black Americans were
descendants of Moroccans and that their
original faith was Islam Ali rejected
terms of the day like Negro coloured and
even black believing that the term Moore
was more accurate the more science
temple has thousands of members in the
1920s across northern cities like
Detroit and Philadelphia and it's
important to note that it was far from
mainstream or Orthodox Islam even the
Quran used by the temple was written by
Ali and derived from various sources
while the more science temple was taking
root a man named Wallace Mars Muhammad
established another non-orthodox black
Islamic movement in 1931 that you're
probably familiar with the Nation of
Islam the nation's purpose was of course
it was far as Muhammad to use the faith
to uplift black Americans and make them
self-reliant and it was under the
leadership of Elijah Muhammad who
assumed leadership in 1934 that the
nation grew into a great political force
it created one of the most influential
Black Liberation figures of the 20th
century we don't advocate violence but
our people that have been the constant
victims of brutality on the part of
America's racists and the government has
found itself either unwilling or unable
to do anything about it Malcolm X a
minister in the Nation of Islam
propagated a simple message uplift black
americans worth in their own eyes and
make them independent and the Nation of
Islam was a foundation of
message especially as it rejected
Christianity and how it had been used by
white supremacy religion whether Islam
or Christianity was a big deal during
the civil rights movement of the 1950s
and 60s religious spaces like mosques
and churches became mobilization centers
because churches and mosques were
community centers and financially
independent they were also places where
people were able to learn skills like
public speaking fundraising and
organizing meetings and it's also why so
many of the leaders of the civil rights
movement were either ministers or active
members in their churches and mosques
there were also efforts by the likes of
ministers and theologians like James H
Cohn to create a black liberation
theology in a 2017 talk at the Yale
Divinity School Cohen summarized a core
of black theology in this way black
power there's not only ambient to the
gospel it's not alien to the gospel but
rather it is the gospel of Jesus in
twentieth-century America so we've
talked about how religion has been for
hundreds of years a central part of
black liberation and how black
communities have dealt with white
supremacy but what role does religion
have to play today in the fight against
systemic racism
well I asked Owen will lead them with
some activists if he thought there was a
place for religion in activism today and
here's what he had to say movement
towards black liberation in the United
States America has become less religious
if we look back at the 1950s and 1960s
it was the black church but also the
mosque under the Nation of Islam that
were the most potent organizing forces
when we look at what's going on right
now the black church is seen as less of
a means or a base for organizing
according to Pew while black Americans
are the most religiously inclined racial
and ethnic group in the country their
church attendance has declined the idea
of religion as a central organizing
force has also shifted in fact black
Americans under 30 are 3 times more
likely to be religiously unaffiliated
than black Americans over 50 and some of
this may have to do with tensions that
may seem to exist between religious
institutions and activism especially on
social positions on issues like LGBTQIA
rights women's representation and
reproductive rights
we can look at black lives matter
movement for instance which is a very
left orientated a much more secular
organization or movement and in fact
there are many within the religious
community that actually are proponents
of black lives matter as a slogan but
don't agree with the tactics of the
actual black lives matter movement in
the 501c3 nonprofit organization and
even though there may be some tension
some religious groups are still involved
in progressive social activism
take for example Reverend William barber
moral Mondays movement world Mondays is
a campaign started in 2013 where church
congregants have been leading protests
every Monday in several state
legislatures against policy is
negatively impacting everything from
voting rights to the climate and even if
the future of religious institutions and
black activist movements is uncertain
will lead is quick to point out what he
sees as the central role religion has
played throughout black American history
it is this religiosity in this
connection to the church into the mosque
that I believe has granted us the
spiritual strength and spiritual power
to continue existing and struggling in
these United States of America
hey guys thanks for watching our video
don't forget to Like share and subscribe
and look who's here with me it's Deena
hi everybody make sure you check out the
direct from playlist where I bring you
underreported stories from all over the
world and we'll see you guys next Sunday